donald trump hired a new spokeswoman a
few months ago she is dramatically and
cartoonishly more unhinged i would say
than any of donald trump's former
spokespeople her name is liz harrington
she went on fox news yesterday and she
claimed listen to this
she claimed that the arizona so-called
audit of the 2020 election results now
that's the election from nine months ago
that's the one
she says that the audit in arizona found
provisionally
275 000
potential fraudulent ballots she also
says nearly 4 000 were falsely certified
and it's all trump trump won trump won
everything according to her let's take a
look at this clip from fox news that
includes 106. here we go if you look at
the preliminary findings from the
independent audit
already we have 275
000 potential fraudulent ballots
how many caveats are there if you look
at the preliminary findings preliminary
meaning meaningless as of yet from the
independent it's not an independent
audit it's also not an audit there are
275
potential fraudulent ballots could there
be more if sands and butts there guys i
just looked at five potential vacation
homes
which have a real preliminary standing
as homes that i might buy do you know
what would happen if i showed up and
tried to get into those homes the police
would be called and so the point she
wants to make of course is trump won
arizona let's continue includes 168 000
that were printed on thin paper outside
of the regulations of
75 maricopa ballots that were supposed
to be mailed out but they have no record
of them ever being sent you also have 18
000 voters who were purged from the
voter rolls who voted in the election
but were purged after the election and
here's a significant one brett if i
could bring up that everything so far i
guess is not significant now she's going
to give us the real significant stuff
the county will not touch
3981 people voted despite registering
after the october 15th court-ordered
deadline and here's the key question
that means maricopa county certified
false results and if we still have a
free country with one set of rules for
every every american this is a
spokeswoman
so it's bad enough when it's jenna ellis
or sydney powell or whatever this is the
this is the official spokeswoman for the
former president of the united states
donald trump nine months after the
election talking about these fraudulent
ballot dumps the votes need to be thrown
out immediately or do we live in a
communist country our votes turn up 100
to nothing no that does not say for
joseph stalin it says for joseph biden
that's in fulton county georgia if we're
going to keep a country free we need to
have these audits to get to the bottom
of it because 100 to nothing is not the
united states of america and we need
these audits to continue to get to the
true results so completely delusional
completely delusional but the point she
wants to make is trump really won
arizona remember the official results in
arizona are that joe biden won but only
by about 11 000 votes so therefore you
know if 275 000 ballots were really
fraudulent then trump would have won
arizona easily that's the point
except it's all completely made up they
are potentially fraudulent
until they are verified and they were
verified within a day or two of election
day i actually have a difficult time
getting a read on liz harrington i can't
tell if she's a liar or completely
delusional something about how she talks
doesn't make it totally clear to me does
she believe this stuff or is she
actually living in a fantasy world
divorced from reality uh is she going
out and saying things she knows to be
lies maybe the two aren't mutually
exclusive maybe she's a liar
and delusional in some sense
but
the particularly horrifying part
is that millions of people in the united
states believe this there are millions
of people in this country who will watch
fox news
and they will hear liz harrington say we
found on a preliminary basis
275 000
potentially fraudulent votes and to them
that means trump won arizona and that
joe biden stole it period without
question end of story
and so much as is the case with trump in
general the fact that trump existed
wouldn't have met much if there weren't
tens of millions of people willing to
vote for him
and the fact that liz harrington is
going around saying this stuff would
mean a lot less if there weren't tens of
millions of people who believed it and
it is a really really ugly situation i
don't see
any way to fix this and speaking of
things i don't see any way how to fix
we get to today's voicemail
one of our sponsors is monk pack i try
to just limit how much sugar intake i
have and it's tough sometimes because
sweet things taste good that's just the
reality and that's why i love monk pack
keto granola bars so much they are sweet
and delicious they're soft and chewy
they've got a slight crunch but each bar
has only one gram of sugar two to three
grams of net carbs and just 140 calories
so they are perfect for anyone doing
keto or low carb or just if you're
trying to limit sugar they come in great
flavors like coconut cocoa chip peanut
butter blueberry almond vanilla these
are not those hard crumbly granola bars
you're used to they're chewy with a ton
of flavor i always have a box in my
pantry it's great for a quick breakfast
or a snack when i'm working monk pack is
giving my audience 20 off your first
order go to monkpack.com and enter the
code pacman at checkout